all right second to last one and uh the
second last moment is i guess just
moment of the year moment of the year a
single moment there are many moments of
this year it's just like one i guess
it's like one single snapshot of the
year there's many
like there's many great moments we've
gone through a lot of them already uh i
think a lot of them like are too long to
be considered a moment yeah they're very
iconic pieces but here are the moments
that you guys voted for
so it's
quantum mumbles the charity stream
announcements wait play play that one
play the clip gary i think it's the five
dollars and i'm thinking for the twenty
dollars none of us think that 250
dollars i'm the main protagonist i think
with the ten dollars thirty one god
needs to watch kintam i look at the five
dollars cherry s do you think it's the
ten dollars thirty two jesse swore i
think of the twenty dollars oh thank you
the five dollars whispering i think the
five dollars no i think it's ten dollars
but okay one one seven thank you for the
ten dollars these nothing but twenty
dollars all right there we've seen this
one already uh they moved among us
play that one
oh no oh no
let me let me check if there's tissue on
the side first
why is it lubed who lubed this
is this like a lubed among us thing
it feels like a monger
i think if if we had like a court of the
year yeah that would definitely lead to
monkeys
among us
honestly like nothing else like
what surprised me is like even looking
back i'm like how did how was i so sure
about that but it was like the only
thing that came to my mind as i was
touching it i was like it's lubed among
us because i remember i was like no
other guesses it's lubed among us
oh my god and then obviously me smelling
cat food yeah so we've seen that one uh
god decides to rob a 12 year old this is
oh
yeah yeah that kid's like 12. what's
stopping us
from taking
oh
we
yo what if uh mirror distracts the
shopkeep by talking and then you you i
go in and nick though you go grab some
potions whatever you can how about that
just wonderful no no murder no murder
needed i love i love that title out of
context yeah that was just that was just
a great scene in general if you if
you're not into tt rpgs nor was i but
i've really had a lot of fun filming
that yeah and if you don't know the
context uh we that the gang decides to
rob a 12 year old
uh merchant naturally it's one day well
just like we tried to rob joey tried to
murder him yeah let's just kill him
let's kill him
and god spells quintessential quint
essential oh [ __ ] if i have to spell
essential
q u i
n t
[Music]
[Laughter]
i literally just got reminded of that
i realized all of these best moments are
from after yeah i noticed that as well
why is that not part of like the dumbest
answers as well
what's the last one the answer is
shagging sheep what's this one in 1881
parliament passed legislation banning
what in wales shagging sheep
uh the answer is shagging sheep oh
not
[Laughter]
oh my god i've never i've never had like
a [ __ ] [ __ ] boner taken out
yeah yeah that was a that was a [ __ ]
debated moment yeah i mean like i'm
surprised a lot of these moments i i
guess because they're like short moments
yeah and they work the best in like a
live stream setting because these are
all amazing [ __ ] i feel that's what
trash tastes after dark is though it's
just a collection of like short bursts
of mercy yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah right
but chill as well i think we don't
really like discuss much we just kind of
have a fun time yeah yeah yeah yeah
exactly
that's why fun games
all right well uh what's the what's the
other thing is the moment of the year
this one i actually don't know actually
that's they're all like fantastic
moments budweiser it's it's got a way i
feel it's bothering it's gonna win some
come on give it a budweiser the moment
of the year goes to
beer tasting budweiser reveal
[Applause]
that was an iconic moment i mean
considering how much this was nominated
in this i think this was like the most
nominated
like all the american viewers came
together and was like we got to nominate
for this one i mean even like the
non-american viewers came together
it was a great moment uh considering how
much we clowned on america it was the
trash taste instant karma mode well what
was the top three ashley yeah uh top was
budweiser review with 29.5 percent of
the vote okay in second place was lubed
among us with 24.7 percent of the vote
thank god
so happy there is a god uh slightly
behind was robbing a 12 year old with
14.3 i robbed the 12 we all did that we
all did it what's your idea guys we did
it was your idea yeah
it was your idea to kill him joey we
didn't mention that
we didn't go for that
i stopped you from doing that joey why
am i why am i the bad guy here
well god was busy deciding which kids to
rob we're gonna read the final award
what's the final award connor yeah of
course it's got to be the best trash
tasty episode of the year according to
you the viewers 50 whole episodes to
choose yeah i
i don't know what it would be so let's
have a look yeah
yeah episode 56 on with chris absolutely
65 that we can't stop arguing that was a
food one that was the chicken that was
the chicken debate one i believe
oh yeah i think this is the chicken
debatable that's the chicken debate yeah
yeah yeah with jan yeah yeah figa
special which came right after it of
course and then we also have uh our
worst food taste this is the one where i
got gone to eat the stuffed crust yeah
yeah that's right
that was that was also the bread episode
yeah oh okay uh and then the the only
special we had this year
so far
and uh and then we had we almost died
which is i think the camping special
right yes yeah
this says one of two is this the second
one this is the second one we just saw
the first okay
yeah
yeah
one of two yeah i know
um oh man i mean obviously you know for
me the cooking special is special
because it's a special yeah
thank you very much for that joey what
what defines special joey yeah
honestly personally would probably vote
for the dream episode okay so it's it's
weird because like i think one of my
favorite to film was the dream episode
because that was a conversation i had
with the boys that i've kind of like
never had with anyone before it was just
like such a weird conversation and i was
just like such like such a
self-discovery and such a discovery of
like oh
no everyone dreams the same way i do i'm
like what's going on that was like so
weird definitely um aside from that
obviously the great chicken debate was
very very
so much the other slide again yeah
yeah
i mean the uh the argument on the figure
special i mean there's a lot of content
episodes honestly these are all [ __ ]
fantastic episodes
yeah i know obviously the way we chose
these you guys basically said which
one's your favorite so yeah yeah yeah we
decided and then we opened voting mm-hmm
um so yeah i guess um
let's just see what it is all right
let's all right
let's wrap it up all right
the
best trash taste episode according to
you guys
from the last year or 50 episodes or
however the [ __ ] long it's been 2022
yeah
is
the anime figure special oh
okay i wasn't expecting that
i mean that was a very good episode
that's great holy [ __ ] because i forgot
this wasn't just the episode this was
just like the build up the mcu yeah yeah
yeah this was the tt mcu basically
um that yeah that was so fun to film as
well i've like what i'm proud of this
for is that our individual like if you
compare our individual videos to last
year
you could tell that we had leveled up oh
absolutely you know what i mean and that
was that was obvious where we like all
of all of our videos like doubled in
length hasn't it yeah definitely
definitely and also not to mention this
year we also had the after dark one as
well right yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah there's a lot to keep up
with i think there's like nine hours of
footage altogether it was a lot out of
the five videos thank you very much for
uh carrying that that's why i think
almost all of them but it turned out
really good you know i think uh yeah all
the arguments aside it was a fan
favorite i mean clearly i mean uh yeah
yeah we had a lot of fun doing it uh
blood pressure was rising but i think
yeah i understand why it was voted yeah
what was the result top three what are
the top three top three uh first place
uh was the figure episode with 22.3 of
the vote wow second place was 100 ways
to die in japan with chris broad oh my
god thank god 20.3 of the vote and in
third place was
the cooking special with 17.9 percent
nice nice nice nice
good to know people still like this
place oh yeah thank god thank you thank
god thank you very much
yeah well i guess that's kind of like
that's kind of it
season two of trash tastes i guess right
until like damn how did you how did you
guys feel season two when compared to
like season one i mean yeah absolutely
yeah that was great
i mean you know it was it was okay right
i'm not gonna say it wasn't me
we could have done more specials but
yeah it was a nightmare with moving and
getting everything all set up to be fair
yeah i'm trying to get after dark all
day yeah yeah i was about to say like to
be fair you know i think because of the
fact that we've really put our strengths
into after dark this year like yeah i
feel that kind of led us away from the
specials a little bit yeah you know i'm
still very proud of off the dock you
know yeah people loving it yeah um sure
you couldn't get more guests on really i
would like to have a few more guests
definitely just like three or four more
guests to mix it up and uh it was just
kind of unfortunate where we couldn't
really find anyone and write timings and
we did find people yeah it was kind of
like and then we had to bulk record it
was kind of old i mean we definitely
thought the borders were going to open
by yeah this second season right yeah
but uh unfortunately yeah i mean i think
we definitely like i think one thing i
would always say about trash days is we
always try to do something new and
something different and i would say like
season two is definitely different from
season one absolutely um and it might
not have been reflected in the main
channel but it was definitely reflected
with like everything we did outside of
the main channel oh yeah because it
wasn't just like the studio move it was
just we really try to we always try to
give you the best content even if it's
all not not all put into one place i
think the proudest thing that i did this
year was definitely like the 24 hour
stream yeah
absolutely
like one thing one massive massive
massive difference from season one and
season two uh is our team behind the
cameras because season one we had malin
and we had ashley uh and that would you
know that was that's all we had and then
we couldn't have done everything that we
did in season two especially something
like the 24 hour stream yeah without the
massive dark shows
yeah all the other stars because the
thing is like
i would love to do more after dark but
logistically it's just so much harder
than main channel videos right
definitely because because like with the
main channel videos we can record that
ahead of time you know we can record
whenever we want also a lot more
planning goes into after dogs yeah the
regular yeah yeah we just like sit down
and talk here you know like we have to
have people like write quizzes plan what
we're going to do we have to schedule
stuff there's a lot more work that goes
into after dark and we really hope you
guys have enjoyed after dark um it will
return when we're back from traveling
around and you know
but in the meantime like hey subscribe
to the channel yeah watch all the after
dark stuff there's plenty of good yeah
no one subscribes to after dark yeah
people watch it people watch after that
but no one subscribes yeah yeah
yeah um what is there anything you guys
are looking forward to in the season
three would you what do you guys want
out of them next year i think we'll have
more guests than we've ever had yeah i
think so i think uh you know they were
going to have more specials than this
year yeah
i know for sure that we're gonna have
more yes because we already have uh
plans yeah yeah you'll get more specials
and hopefully we can just uh make it all
better yeah like we will continue
endeavoring to like push the envelope
with not just being a podcast channel uh
but just being a show but just being a
show being do we all we want to do is
like make good content and we hope you
guys can see that whether that's on like
the main channel or anything else we
choose to do
um we're always going to be trying to
push the envelope to try and do
something new and one thing without
spoiling anything that we do or anything
that was coming up um we're definitely
going to be using more budget in season
three
like a lot more buzzfeed things are
coming yeah yeah yeah yeah
so don't think that you've you've
reached the end of trash taste we have a
lot a lot of excitement
baby this is it's always just the
beginning okay 100 episodes yeah yeah
yeah